thank you for being here thank you for
having me you look lovely sexy the whole
package yeah I'm wearing underwear and
people get psyched when you're not guys
do my boyfriend has been mentioning
recently about his ex-girlfriend like
he'll drop just drop little factoids
the other day he goes um you know she
just never wore panties like ever like
I'm not weird and I was like she sounds
poor like what
it doesn't sound erotic to it so it's
just it's five for 25 of Victoria's
Secret very easy and I don't know I've
just always wore underwear I don't know
it's the kind of been like my thing yeah
it's always just been my thing but I did
the other day I tried no underwear all
day and it was um it was hot it was I
have to admit was sexy it was just cuz I
said my pants like early on in the
afternoon and so I had to ditch that
song it is it all day good point it
wasn't all that ya know yeah and I yeah
so and but I was like this is sexy like
I got it you know so and um and it's
just it's just a lot of pressure I'm I
just turned 28 in June of 2012 and it's
it's hard it's that I just the more I'm
here the worm-like the most likely
scenario for me to be discovered in LA
is like naked in a marsh you know what I
mean why do I say that that's an odd
thing to say um you know that's just the
reality of it I'm just a scared woman
like I um I don't know what's gonna
happen to me I don't run at night cuz
you can't you shouldn't it's very
dangerous
as a woman right I see women running at
night and so a part of me is like go
girl but the other parts like inside
like urine it's scary 9 out of 10 times
there's a guy chasing them if you look
every time you just start looking even
if it's a guy walking his dog in the
same direction behind her still chasing
ya roll down my window I'll be like
leave her alone
really you have you have a pretty dark
vision of what could happen to you here
in LA yes every time I walk into a
grocery store where you see the security
footage like at you I was kind of like
suckin cuz I'm like maybe this is my
final moment you know that still be up
Nancy Grace I watched so many of those
shows like and she was never seen again
that I do think about that like oh wait
are you seeing that with my little
target basket like she's like that was
my last moment so I just got to look my
best okay
I worry about you because these are very
very dark thoughts
you